hello yay I had to say I'm so
embarrassed that you all saw my dirty
desktop over there I usually make a
folder called desktop and put everything
in it before I give a talk and show up
off my desktop but oh well didn't get a
chance to do that today um yeah the
algorithms of CSS I'm really excited to
give this talk @j SLA I think this is
especially a talk that's great for
JavaScript developers or people who are
you know maybe more on the side of
JavaScript and CSS to here but like
Brian said I did this talk at CSS Compu
in Berlin last month in June and it was
very exciting really fun to be in Berlin
and so I'm giving this talk a version
number so 1.5.2 is this version so
there's some new stuff in here anyways
umm nice white board so hello my name is
Laura shank and I've been in LA for like
a year and a half it's ok I'm kind of
I'm from the east coast we'll see um
this is my property on Twitter RS 126
very exciting and I am a front-end and
WordPress developer scratch that out for
design engineer because they just got a
job I've been freelancing for oil and I
got a job in the title as design
engineer and I'm like ok like the
front-end developer works too but design
engineer that sounds really cool job
titles are weird
um ok so mine a little about my
background so CSS has really been um
kind of the language that I would relate
to most for most of my development
career I started coding like eight years
ago or so in college I was an art major
and I started learning to build
WordPress sites as a way to make money
and that kind of turned into a career
that I really love but CSS and HTML
particular are these really accessible
languages that you get really immediate
results from like visual results so
anybody with a visual background
probably takes to them really quickly um
but there's this kind of weird bias in
the industry where it's not real
programming like mmm not real coding so
I was like oh this is bizarre but it's
not look
so I went on this journey to learn
computer science mainly because I got a
pretty major whiteboarding interview and
I was like oh god I had to learn to
write algorithms now wow this is like
sort of relevant to my day-to-day work
so I wanted to bridge this gap between
CSS and computer science because as I
started learning more computer science I
was like this is so cool and fun and
like CSS is kind of boring now because I
don't have these programming challenges
in the same way when I write CSS as I
did when I was working on this
algorithms I'll go to computer science
studies and so throughout this process
of connecting computer science and CSS
CSS went from like oh god I'm writing
instructions this is so boring to like
whoa like CSS is unbelievable it is
unbelievable what CSS does it's so cool
that we don't have to do all of that and
so I hooked to in this talk and part a
little bit of that enthusiasm and I
encourage everybody to kind of peek
under the hood a little bit and see what
CSS is really doing okay so I started
out my research with this question is a
programming language followed up with a
fire emoji because that's definitely a
hot topic or definitely elicits a lot of
like like gut responses from people like
yes/no so I asked this question on
Twitter and got a variety of responses
so we have 42% yes it's a programming
language 50% no and 8% I'm not sure and
this is really interesting because the
yeses we're like yes absolutely yes CSS
is a programming language and the nose
were like no I don't I don't I don't
list it in my list of languages or like
no I don't really see it as a
programming language kind of more
opinion-based and I was like okay let's
stop like what what's going on here why
is there this weird discrepancy like
such a polar discrepancy and so I was
like what is a programming language it
turns out programming language the many
definitions I've read in it did a good
bit of research about this it's a
language of instructions for a computer
it's kind of paraphrasing Wikipedia and
others but there are a few really
pointed good blog posts about what the
programming languages and how we define
language and the world of computer
science it's important for that
definition to be really broad because
programming is really a language of
instructions for computer and how the
how those our instructions are formatted
can vary greatly so that kinda brings us
to programming paradigms how many of you
are familiar with programming paradigms
okay few people yeah so these two words
in particular should probably be
familiar ish but a programming paradigm
is in general a category or a model for
how programming how a programming
language works or how a program is
written so they're kind of big picture
categories or paradigms so not
necessarily super specific so imperative
is kind of a big one and then
declarative and that's these are like
the two umbrella the umbrella paradigm
so you can kind of dig in between dig
into each of those more either way so
imperative is how so when we have an
imperative programming language or
tonkin computer how to do something and
a declarative language tells the
computer what to do and the main
difference there is the presence of
control flow in an imperative language
and no control flow in a declarative
language so what control flow means is
you're kind of controlling the execution
of statements the execution order of
statements so in an imperative language
of programs read top to bottom and you
might be jumping all around in order the
execution the execution order of
statements and in a declarative language
that execution in those logic that logic
is more baked into individual commands
so you might just say like do this and
it's doing a whole bunch of things but
you're really just giving it that one
instruction so what kind of languages
fall into these categories imperative
languages are what we usually think of
so JavaScript Ruby C++ Python etc and
declarative languages are often
domain-specific sequel is a
domain-specific declarative language for
databases HTML okay is it a main
specific declarative programming
language and of course our beloved CSS
falls under this category all right
there we go yeah
I was like oh my god yes did it like it
proved it like okay
and so instructions for a computer like
okay got it um obviously they're very
like writing Python and writing CSS are
very different but I think they can be
there's a lot of interesting things that
come from looking them under at them
under the same lens so CSS further is
turing-complete
CSS plus HTML turing-complete refers to
the ability to simulate a Turing machine
which is the ability to compute the
problem of a certain complexity and CSS
and HTML can do that together CSS has
math there's a calc function it has
functions and variables and so it's like
what's going on why isn't it a
programming language so I would ask like
why not yeah there's a lot of
differences and it is this domain
specific language and domain-specific
languages in general are a really
different topic um but why not
the web is declarative in a lot of ways
so we have a lot of power in telling a
computer what to do instead of how to do
it like a lot of api's are written in
declarative fashion so CSS is
domain-specific declarative programming
language 100% okay it's a little bit of
a mouthful and it's like well I got it I
got to include that declarative
domain-specific part otherwise it sounds
weird
CSS developers program the layout of
webpages
more like boxes though so be like dig
into it's like Oh programmers of boxes
like I like that but then if you think
about how a browser really works and
it's like they kind of all become images
after a while so cuz I don't I'd
represent know that in mind we're gonna
do browser internals in less than five
minutes there's a new part of the talk
and I try to because it's important to
have this background in this mental
model for how a browser works how many
how many people have taken the time to
really look into the inner workings of a
browser okay well good yeah this like
this really changed the way I did
everything it's kind of funny like you
can write web great code and build
websites and not necessarily understand
how a browser works that's how like
abstracted our tools are from what they
actually work with from the domain and
so to speak so okay here's me on the
computer
obviously and there's a server obviously
and when I use a computer I'm like okay
server like typing in the browser give
me data and servers like okay here is
data great okay bye
we're done yeah so smart client server
HTTP requests and that response from a
server is given in bytes and those are
bytes of HTML CSS and JavaScript code so
we can inside browser we take those
bytes and those bytes are parsed into
tokens until the if you kind of picture
all these bytes which stand for certain
letters and then the parser looks and
grabs looks for certain combinations of
characters and then assigns meaning to
those characters in the form of tokens
and as it's going through those tokens
it's saying like oh is this HTML is the
CSS is this JavaScript and it turns
those into trees so we have the Dom
beloved dawn and there's also a CSS
which is the tree representation of
styles and that information is then
taken and turned into a different tree
which is the render tree or the style
rule tree and this rule tree is
essentially a list of instructions for
laying out a browser web page I am
totally skipping JavaScript FYI
in this description of a browser
algorithms let's yes come on so the that
render tree is kind of a blueprint of
instructions for laying out a web page
and laying out all these boxes in the
layout process in a browser if you've
ever heard of reflow that refers to
triggering this layout process it's like
a recursive process for laying out all
of these boxes based on the instructions
in the render tree then all those boxes
are painted and so they become images so
it's kind of like a bunch of little
images laid out on top of each other and
then there's the composite step where
there's a certain set of CSS properties
that are applied after Pete and
everything is kind of composited into
one big image which is then rendered on
to the browser or rather ended on to
your computer so rendering yay so CSS is
a domains
specific language to program like this
rendering process it's kind of how I
like to look at it okay switching gears
slightly to algorithms yay I like
drawing these little monsters there's a
couple of them in here okay so
algorithms another definition a
well-defined computational procedure
that takes input and produces output
anybody read well if you've read it in
its entirety that's amazing but Thomas
Korman has this introduction to
algorithms book that's kind of the
canonical textbook assigned in intro
computer science classes but I recommend
looking it up a little dense but
definitely a comprehensive overview of
algorithms so if we take a that
definition and put that in a little
framework we've got inputs and we've got
outputs input sorting sorting is a great
use for algorithms so we've got an
unsorted list output is gonna be a
sorted list what happens in the middle
well well here look at name a sorting
algorithm merge sort
oh whoops bubble sort first what was
that one lazy sort that sounds like my
kind of sorting algorithm selects I'm
not actually lazy everyone but selection
sort bubble sort merge sort quick sort
okay yeah these are all solutions to the
sorting problem cool let's look at an
implementation of bubble sort cool Wow
bubble sort in all its glorious so for
anybody who's not familiar bubble sort
is kind of known as like a really slow
sorting algorithm um but it's a good
intro intro to algorithms kind of thing
so this is imperative JavaScript it's
imperative code so the computers gonna
read this program and kind of jump
around between statements there's a for
loop so it's gonna jump back up to
execute certain code um good heart
because like we like JavaScript of
course so if this was declarative code
if I wanted to do declare it a bubble
sort all this would be hidden that
somewhere and I would just say like
bubble sort basically
okay um let's look at another framework
oh you think that's funny huh sorry so
good okay let's have another Algar input
a tall stack of boxes uh-huh see where
this is going out put a row of boxes
what's in the middle mmm display flex
perhaps flow to left gas floats still
have their place
my friends um okay let's take a look at
the implementation of display flex
groundbreaking this wow that's a
declarative CSS that's so cool I love it
okay what so what's happening under the
hood here like what is display flex I'll
show you a very tiny piece of display
flex in a moment um this is the
difference between kind of declarative
code and imperative code declarative was
what you see on the top and there's this
whole like huge backing of imperative
code underneath so for CSS that
declarative part is the browser or
rather uh the tip of the iceberg and
then agrees we have C++ or a rust code
so this is the source code of a browser
and I spent really long time looking
through browser source code and it's
really fun actually
especially after I had this all this
kind of algorithms background knowledge
I was like this is really addicting to
take what I know really well CSS and map
it to the browser and what's under the
hood okay so this is a little bit of
rust code from the source of servo which
is the browser engine in Firefox quantum
you can read this if you want to flex
wrap maybe is my comment I'm not sure if
this is actually flex wrap but this is a
little tiny snippet of the probably
thousands of lines that make up what
flex box does and we don't have to write
this
that's pretty awesome imperative rust
love it Firefox okay so what like so
okay yeah I know I knew there were some
kind of browser code that was happening
under the hood of CSS obviously so this
is when like when I learned this and
started thinking of
as I was reading CSS this is one CSS
went from like Oh God instructions
boring to like whoa what is this doing
like there is so much computer science
all over CSS and when you start to think
about it it's like oh it's incredible I
love it ok let's take a look at another
algorithm does anybody know what this
one might be the Cascade who loves the
Cascade ok people cool who strongly
dislikes the Cascade less people cool I
like it I feel like the Cascade gets a
lot of flack because it can be a real
gotcha for people starting to learn CSS
and it's something very unique to the
domain of CSS so let's look at the
Cascade as an algorithm because that's
what it is an algorithm that combines
property values from different sources
so that's from Mozilla developer Network
this is also the first thing that comes
up when you google algorithms and CSS
maybe my talk will come up now but this
is really um a little background to cuz
we're gonna do some terms here and CSS
the different components the kind of
grammar so to speak of CSS as a language
very specific name so selector is what
you use what you're selecting in order
to style so that could be your class or
even be like a pseudo element a general
selector and then we have property and
value and those together are called a
declaration and then the whole thing is
called a rule or a rule set so I think
it's important to use these terms really
intentionally and that's what everything
is referred to as in the source of a
browser and in spec so it helps a lot to
use those terms algorithm of the Cascade
valley ok input we have our array of
values that are collected from various
areas output it's a sort essentially a
sorted array of those value or not a per
se but a sorted list of those values so
the Cascade takes these values from
different areas so if you have a
paragraph that has a style from the
browser and then a style from various
areas it's going to
um and then we have some steps in there
and the steps are sorting by importance
and origin specificity and the order
specified cool you get a winner um I'm
gonna go on too much about that because
you can read this back and that's like
going through algorithm step by step
it's not that exciting so I was like
okay I want to look at this in the
browser like cascade magic this is what
I expected to find I was like function
cascade magic and guess what I found
function cascade I was like wow so this
is probably not that actual like the
mule cascade it's and there's many
definitions of the Cascade throughout
the source code but I like this is a fun
slide cool um so where do you where do
you see us if you want to kind of peek
under the hood and take a look into a
browser search fox org has the source
code of Firefox and then chromium.org
yes chromium dougherty's the open source
rendering engine called blink which is a
fork of WebKit and that is written in
C++ which I found a little more
difficult to look around because it's
also a much older codebase so my process
here was to kind of go back and forth
between the spec of something and then
see if I can find that implementation in
the source code it's pretty cool and
let's take a look at the Cascade and the
browser so in the inspector
and I'll go through those quickly so I'm
sure we've probably used the inspector
before or dev tools so here are some
declarations and some rule sets and we
can see this one value is kind of a
winning value so that's one that's not
crossed out links are a good example of
this because a lot of times there are
several styles that are applying to a
link then we can also hit computed here
so the computed tab will show us a
little different view that's based on
all the properties so rather than
showing you the rule sets you can look
at the computed view to see different
properties properties and values now
I'll show us everything that is sorted
here so this is kind of that other side
of the spectrum not sorted lists in the
output and also notice this RGB
so the value that was defined in the
stylesheet was a hex code and this is
showing us a computed value of RGB so
one other step in rendering is that all
of these values that we write a lot of
the values in CSS that we write are for
our purpose
like percentages or viewport units those
are for us to read and the browser has
to ultimately turn everything into
pixels in RGB it's kind of interesting
um we can also look at this browser
styles checkbox here and that will kind
of show us that indeed every property
does have a value so that's kind of an
interesting concept so you can always
like reset properties back to their
original values okay I wanna have a
little story here of writing CSS this
was a beautiful mock-up that I got from
a kind agency I was working with a
little bit ago so it's like the mobile
mock this is not this is a drawing of
the monk obviously hopefully that was
obvious but there's like there's this
beautiful ocean on top and now I was
like okay cool like yeah we can split
this up into two images it's like high
res ocean thing and then the bottom one
will be a little transparent PNG but
it'll be a PNG so it's a little smaller
I was like okay this sounds great so I
started writing it started writing the
code couldn't play out and I was like oh
my god these are completely different
aspect ratios so like oh so over here
it's like oh they're totally different
like this cuz it's not working I'm
having to do some weird annoying
positioning stuff so I started writing
CSS with a hammer which is what kind of
the default is you're like keep trying
things you're like oh my god just work
like keep trying stuff over and over and
over again and eventually it'll work
right um come via probably you'll
probably figure it out eventually and
then the next person that has to read it
it's gonna be like what is going on so I
mean we do this with more languages than
just CSS for sure but I would say no I
was like no I'm not gonna write CSS my
hammer right now I'm doing all this
research about algorithms and like CSS
is a programming language why don't I
like break down this problem into
and algorithm why not so I thought about
this framework and I was like what are
my inputs are these couple images and a
device and outputs are my program images
my program boxes setting together
perfectly so it's like okay what would
look like how do you write an algorithm
I was like well I mean studying this
damn whiteboarding interview and there's
like a defined process for how to write
algorithms in a whiteboarding interview
so first you plan out your algorithm
then you call with a brute force
solution and then you walk through it
and then you optimize your solution so I
was like what would this look like if I
did applying this process to CSS so I
started by planning it out so think
about how I want these boxes to respond
at each device size and it's so
important to like bacon responsive
design from the get-go as soon as you
start writing CSS be resizing your
browser all the time and then you don't
map it out a little bit so the more i've
started thinking about CSS like this the
more I feel like you use pen and paper
and map out some values I'm thinking
about it algorithmically a bit more and
I write some pseudocode pseudocode CSS
sure and this eventually can kind of
become my styles and I change it a bunch
but then brute force solution
aka spaghetti yeah that's funny
like we're allowed to write bad code
that's okay so I my brute force CSS
smelly CSS or some qualities of brute
force CSS part of a system no definitely
not magic numbers absolutely do I have a
bunch of hard-coded pixel values for
sure to do comments everywhere also
absolutely does it work maybe a little
bit cool like it's just your time to
look play around figure out what you're
looking for try to get to work um and my
walk through step so it's like resizing
the browser all the time I'm sure a lot
of us do this and it's like oh I'm not
sure users do that but I do so it's got
a word and then optimization so or
optimized
which also includes refactoring so kind
of over and over and over again
Wow you like that over there laughing
okay
so we take our smelly CSS and transform
it into a beautiful flower of course
that's how code optimization works right
what are some qualities of optimized CSS
part of a system yes so how many of you
work within a design system or some kind
of component architecture okay that's a
good number of hands
um I personally when I've done this I
find it so hard to write to like write
new CSS with that architecture in mind
so I started you now is kind of like
write the crap CSS get it working and
then be like okay how can I incorporate
this into my system what change do I
need to add a new component or new
whatever but get it working first then
think about all this stuff does it use
algorithm so does it use algorithms like
flexbox grids CSS grid it has a ton of
amazing algorithms intentional cascade
so the Cascade can be some pretty
incredible like baked in declarative
logic and especially in terms of browser
support so try to embrace that to do
comments hmm probably some of them still
but get rid of them okay and I'll do
this slide just to kind of show us my
favorite optimized CSS things so custom
properties plus the VAR function I would
love to do another talk about that game
changer with CSS custom properties
amazing per component grid layouts CSS
grid if you haven't spent you know an
hour something go to CSS grid garden and
do the exercises it's amazing it's so
fun umm calc math is great flexbox yeah
transforms and positioning transforms
are incredibly performant properties to
animate they're great viewport height
would aspect ratios less media queries
yeah hearts for everything okay yellow
light I want to show some couple
algorithms here as we're finishing out
this is an algorithm for my wonderful
ocean I'm not sure this may or may not
have a pointer oh yay okay so
setting some custom properties at the
top it's like setting up some values
some pretty cool CSS grid stuff going on
this property is going to be adjusted in
a media query that is not present on the
slide etc so very intentional code that
can I took awhile to fine-tune this is
some centering code here so the oldest
trick in the book for centering is kind
of Center and then do use a transform to
go up 50% which is what this push value
would be another photo strip these
slides we posted later magic maybe okay
and then my favorite algorithm fizzbuzz
in CSS no problem
absolutely okay cool so back to the kind
of higher-level thinking here of what we
can do with algorithms in CS hasn't like
algorithmic thinking about CSS I think
this can really help to smooth out that
design design to development workflow
and can be a conversation starter
between designers so if we have our
wonderful designer and developer here of
course unfortunately this process is not
all puppies and kittens but we can
pretend it is here talk about algorithms
together yay or maybe you have a
designer slash developer you can talk
about algorithms with yourself he'll
help smooth smooth things out a little
bit it can be a nice conversation piece
so inputs um inputs are your design so
are your designs mock-ups sure is it on
a napkin
maybe that's cool that's an input is it
a little mock-up of a component also an
input and the output it's gonna be your
rendered code so responsible on
responsive on all device sizes and
what's the algorithm in there so design
systems and component libraries like
absolutely at a high level the
combination of different components can
be thought of as algorithms your CSS so
any CSS D right yes okay
that's gotta be my favorite it's cute
okay conclusion um let's try this I
don't know maybe not write CSS with the
hammer as much but I found when I
started thinking about CSS as like as
programming I was like okay I'm gonna
approach these problems with a
whiteboard a little more like spend ten
minutes and like draw out the widths and
heights of things and so you can kind of
come up with a more thought-out solution
rather than that spur of the moment like
just banging out instructions
um and also look at the biggest takeaway
of this whole process is like the code
we write and it's applies across the
board especially in the JavaScript land
of frameworks like the code rewrite is
oftentimes kind of the tip of the
iceberg and our mission as developers I
think is to fill in like the bottom part
with what we're learning so can I figure
out learn inch by inch what makes our
code work also in this idea for a cool
really annoying app called the mindful
CSS Bell so you can go off like every 30
minutes and be like read the spec like
do you actually know what this is doing
through the spec this is cool
doesn't that sound like a great out
thank you definitely is that for
JavaScript to any infrared light so the
end of the day did I bridge this gap
between CSS and computer science well
cuz figured out was more like a big
grassy area of little pools so they're
all part of one things so CSS C++ HTML
javascript computer science is a very
broad spectrum that this is all part of
I also want to just mention this talk
quickly by someone named Fillion who did
a talk called what is programming anyway
and she talks about her journey as a
computer scientist she was researching
domain-specific languages and like what
is programming and there's this notion
of like that's not real programming and
that's a weird thing in the tech
community to have someone who's like
really excited about something to be
turned away by their community so I
think that's just something to keep in
mind and like maybe like math and
engineering aren't the only metaphors in
ways we can talk
we do Sochi and this talk talks about
how programming is writing and Mises
writing as a metaphor for writing
programs which i think is really
beautiful and she also draws her slides
and I was like what so other people do
this this is great
so above all like why not so no like CSS
it's great a little monster and thank
you all so much
[Applause]
you